hello everyone and welcome to a Koi of
biosciences webinar series today's
presentation validating multiplexed
antibody panels for pancreatic research
applications is presented by dr. Diane
Saunders and dr. Grady Carlson I'm
Christie jewel of Labatt's and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laborat and brought to you by a Koya
Biosciences to learn more about our
sponsor please visit Akoya bio com
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that the season is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use that
ask a question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
first today we have dr. Grady Carlson
technical application scientist Akoya
Biosciences following dr. Carlson we
have dr. Diane Saunders staff scientist
power member Sylva research group
Vanderbilt University Medical Center
for complete biographies on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of the screen
dr. Carlson you may now begin your
presentation
traduction my name is Grady Carlson and
I am a technical application scientist
for a Koya Biosciences today I'm going
to be talking about the codec solution
which allows for highly multiplexed
tissue profiling for single cell spatial
analysis
the need for multi marker spatial
analysis arises from a multitude of
publications that have demonstrated that
not only the composition of a tissue but
also the localization of the cells that
comprise that tissue a significant for
understanding biological outcome for
example in a 2017 paper by bernie fox's
lab they demonstrated that in oral
squamous cell carcinoma the sheer number
and composition of the tissue in terms
of the Fox p3 T regulatory cells did not
stratify patient populations but when
they looked at the spacial proximity of
those T regulatory cells relative to the
cd8 T killer cells the patient
population was stratified this is just
one example of how we need to be able to
understand how spell how cells are
spatially related in the tissue now a
Koya has two platforms for multi markers
facial spatial analysis there is the
fnatic portfolio which allows for
high-throughput tissue multiplexing via
ople staining and multispectral unmixing
and then there is codex which is Co
detection by indexing which is a high
parameter modality for a multi marker
spatial analysis and this allows for the
detection of a high number of markers on
cells with single cell resolution and
we'll be talking about codecs today
so the basic chemistry underlying
antigen detection using codex is this we
have primary antibodies that are DNA
bar-coded and these primary antibodies
are going to bind their target antigens
inside of the tissue we're going to
reveal where these primary antibodies
have bound to their target antigens
using DNA barcodes that are bound to
four fours
we call these codex reporters so these
codex reporters have the reverse DNA
barcode as the DNA barcode conjugated to
the antibody and this is how we're going
to be able to visualize where these
antibodies have found their target
antigens inside of tissue
for codex is to first stain the tissue
with a cocktail of DNA bar-coded primary
antibodies shown here these antibodies
are going to be fixed to the tissue so
that they are not removed in the
following processes
going to reveal where these antibodies
have found their target antigen using a
one-step reveal process in each codex
cycle now this is an isothermal process
by which the codex reporters are
hybridized the DNA bar-coded antibodies
this automation for revealing where
these antibodies are inside of tissue is
provided by codex and so we're going to
reveal image and then remove our codex
reporters this codex cycle then can be
repeated in a second codex cycle in the
third so that we can collect all of our
target markers in as many cycles as we
need
so here I'm showing that in each codex
cycle we're collecting three targets as
well as Daffy so we can image all of our
target biomarkers using codex for a
total of over forty markers
you
so codex has three components there's
the Codex reagents
there's the fluidics control which
automates both the fluidics and the
imaging automation and the codex
software
the codex creations are a flexible
system we have the ability to use
validated antibodies provided by a coil
and we also have custom reagents for you
so you can conjugate DNA barcodes to
your own antibodies if that's something
that you would like to do
to that end there are three types of
codex antibodies we have codex
inventoried antibodies and these are
validated and sold as a complete a say
we have codex screened antibodies which
are tested for barcode and reporter
compatibility and these are not sold by
Akoya but they are user conjugated and
then we have codex community antibodies
which are tested and shared by codex
users and they're not tested or sold by
a quote and again that user conjugation
is required
so here is an example of codecs
compatible antibodies for human fresh
frozen mouse fresh frozen and human FFP
it te tissue so codex is compatible with
both fresh frozen and FFPE tissue and
the markers is compatible with at this
point are shown here and we're always
building in more markers to be
compatible with codex
codex also allows control of the
fluidics for full automation of the
system
here we're seeing the integration of the
Codex insert with an insert with an
inverted microscope and so what we're
able to do is place this codex insert on
the microscope stage
and then we have our tissue placed on a
coverslip which fits within that codex
insert that sits on the stage so that
we're able to complete the entire
imaging revealing process with the
tissue in the microscope stage this
allows for full automation of the
process
the summary we're going
a section are tissue onto a coverslip
we're then going to incubate our tissue
with a cocktail of DNA bar-coded
primary antibodies
this tissue is then going to be inserted
into the Codex insert which sits on the
microscope stage and the full
integration of codex with the microscope
can be seen here we're then going to use
codex to automate both the fluidics and
the imaging processes to acquire three
markers in every codex cycle
here we can see codex Automation used
for ditching all of our images together
for a complete 41 marker image of a 1
centimeter squared human tonsil tissue
and of course in this particular image
we're only showing six markers because
visualizing 41 at the same time would be
rather challenging
in addition to controlling the
automation codex is also able to analyze
the images once they've been captured
so we have three components to the
software there is the codex instrument
manager which is going to be responsible
for controlling the fluidics as well as
the microscope there is the codex
analysis manager which is going to be
responsible for data processing
including formatting the data and
allowing for cell segmentation and
clustering and then there's the
multiplex analysis viewer which is going
to allow us to interpret our data and
perform the analysis
the data that are produced by codecs
come in some simple formats the cells
are segmented and these segmented cells
in the image produce an FCS file and we
also have TIFF images now also in this
FCS file we have saito metric data for
each cell that's segmented as well as
that cells XY coordinates and this is
what allows us to do spatial analysis on
the cells in our image because we have
both set a metric data to determine the
phenotype and then spatial analysis to
determine the spatial location of that
cell inside of tissue
we can create populations and identify
populations of cells using a couple
different strategies one of those
strategies is to use a flow gating
strategy shown here where we can
identify populations in the tissue while
we gate them the other strategy is to
perform clustering where we cluster the
data and then identify cells or
populations using those clusters
once we've created our populations we
can then map them in the tissue using
the Voronoi plot shown here and we can
see that with over 40 markers available
to us in this case we're using 20 plus
failure phenotypes I believe this
particular tissue is stained with 29
markers in a tertiary of employed
follicle of breast cancer we can see
that they we have complex phenotypes in
a number of them we can have a number of
them because of the multitude of markers
available to us and the Verona plot
shown here is actually constructed based
on the cells nearest neighbors and it's
this construction of the Verona plot
that allows us to evaluate which cells
are highly interacting or weakly
interacting
interactions whether it's more
interacting or less interacting can be
calculated and visualized in this log
odds ratio shown here and this
interaction matrix those cells shown in
red or if they share a red square that
means that they're highly interacting
and the probability of seeing them
interacting in this image is high
whereas if they're shown in blue that
means that they're weakly interacting or
they're less interacting the probably
the probability of seeing those two
cells together in the image is low
so in conclusion the codec system
enables highly multiplexed
immunofluorescence for over 40 markers
imaging across the whole tissue or in
selected regions of interest allows for
conversion of existing fluorescence
microscope into high dimensional cell
analysis tool it's compatible with FFPE
and fresh frozen samples and we're soon
coming out with cell spread
compatibility it does not degrade the
tissue and it's compact and affordable
and now I will turn it over to dr.
Saunders
thanks dr. Carlson and thanks to a Koya
for the invitation to speak today I work
in a research lab within the Vanderbilt
diabetes center and I'll be sharing some
of our initial studies with the codec
system to give you a quick preview I'll
first introduce some of the experimental
goals of our research group and talk
about how codecs is well suited to help
answer the questions that we're asking
then I'll get into our experience with
custom antibody conjugation and building
a tissue specific panel for studying the
human pancreas
to disclosures on one while we are
experienced with immunohistochemistry in
general this is our first time using a
multiplex system and second we've had
the codec system for only about three or
four months so the data that I'll be
showing you today is relatively
preliminary so in the powers and Versova
research group were particularly
interested in understanding cellular
niches during pancreatic development and
also in the context of disease
pathophysiology the pancreatic islet
microenvironment is composed of a lot of
diverse cell types so if you think about
the pancreas as an organ it sits below
the liver in the body cavity and it's
really a bi functional organ so composed
of two compartments exocrine and
endocrine the extra crane compartment
makes up about 98% of the mass and it
consists of a snare cells that secrete
digestive enzymes into a branch ductal
network that abusin to the duodenum and
then scattered throughout those
throughout that exocrine tissue our
islets of langerhans or islets which are
small clusters of cells that are
composed of endocrine cells that secrete
hormones to regulate blood glucose and
islet some cells are really these kind
of mini organs that are made up of alpha
and Delta cells also Delta and beta
cells sorry and these are endocrine
cells that secrete hormones that help
regulate your blood glucose but it's
also important to remember what we
consider the islet micro environment or
other cell types that come into close
contact with the endocrine cells so
those include nerves as well as blood
vessels which are structurally composed
of endothelial cells and also act as a
conduit for immune cells such as
macrophages to enter the tissue
our lab is primarily focused on studying
human tissue and so we have a robust
infrastructure in order to be able to
answer some of these important questions
about human biology and so the way that
this is set up is that we work with a
number of different organ procurement
organizations around the country and
when a organ becomes available for
research we communicate within our team
and then actually ship that organ
directly to our collaborator in
Pittsburgh and there she's able to
isolate those eyelets or small clusters
of functional cells and also take serial
sections of the tissue so in that way we
can study both the function of islets as
well as the overall tissue morphology
from the same organ and at that point
tissue and islets get shipped to
Vanderbilt as well as our collaborators
around the country so this processing of
the pancreas as I mentioned is what
we've developed shouldn't be able to
answer complex questions about both
function and overall tissue architecture
so the primary way that we are able to
do this is by taking serial sections of
the tissue and processing it for
different imaging modalities and other
types of experiments so for example we
have a protocol that allows us to fix
tissue for electron microscopy we also
save some as fresh frozen tissue as well
as formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded and
then finally a lightly fixed OCT
embedded which I'll speak to a little
bit more later and then from the the
region's directly adjacent to these were
able then to isolate islets and these
are used to perform functional and
metabolic studies as well as perform
some immune studies particularly in
healthy pink Ryota and those affected by
type 1 and type 2 diabetes so that what
I'll be focusing on in this presentation
and showing you in some of these codex
images are these lightly fixed tissues
and this was a protocol that was
developed by dr. Marcella bruce'll who
recognized that the traditional ways of
processing tissues were not adequate for
the types of tissue morphology analysis
that we were trying to do so what she
developed was
a protocol in which the tissues are
lightly fixed in a 4% pair of
formaldehyde solution and then washed
and equilibrated in a sucrose gradient
and this really we found is able to
preserve the tissue architecture in a
way that the flash frozen or
formalin-fixed tissues were not we're
not quite up to speed
as I mentioned one area of interest for
our research team is understanding how
endocrine cells interact and communicate
during postnatal pancreas development so
here I'll be showing you a couple of
traditional immunohistochemical images
where Dappy is shown in blue and
endocrine cells are shown in green red
and white so you can see that just after
birth under console's are quite dense
with a lot of individual cells and just
small clusters around the periphery here
of the tissue and then as the pancreas
grows rapidly along with the whole body
these small clusters of cells gradually
coalesce into larger islets and overall
you can see in this last image under the
childhood category the islets are
becoming less densely distributed and
this is occurring because the assen or
tissue is expanding at a much more rapid
pace and so there are fewer islets shown
here and kind of the same the same size
of image frame and if you look at the
kind of zoom into the islets themselves
you'll see that the overall architecture
changes during this first decade of life
as well so in the early period after
birth and during neonatal and infancy
stages you see a real core mantle
structure with beta cells and shown in
green there in the middle of the islet
structure and then alpha and Delta cells
kind of surrounding in the periphery but
by childhood as you conceived by this
last image the alpha beta and Delta
cells are really fully intermingled and
this is reminiscent of what an adult
islet looks like
so overall during this first decade of
life we're seeing drastic changes in
islet density as well as rearrangement
of endocrine cells and adult adult beta
cells really have a very low
proliferative capacity and so it's
thought that these these early processes
of both endocrine cell expansion and
rearrangement may affect the future
susceptibility of an individual to
diabetes and so it's particularly
important that we study this time period
and it's also the case that it's during
these first few years of life that
autoimmunity which is an important
component of type 1 diabetes is first
observed so for those two reasons we're
very interested in understanding more
about the cellular events that are
occurring
so one active area of research in our
lab is looking at the context of type
one diabetes which is has an autoimmune
component so here I'm just showing an
image of an islet that's outlined in a
red color along with immune cells cd45
positive they're shown in brown and so
you can see by this image and the one
below that there are a great deal of
immune cells that are localized around
the islet of the onset of type one
diabetes so we're interested in asking
questions like which other cell types
are involved in this immune infiltration
as well as the signaling molecules that
are involved so what types of cytokines
or receptors are maybe mediating these
events and then we're also interested in
understanding how underpin cells
interact with with immune cells in an in
a regular environment so I'm showing
here an image of a marker called NTP ds3
which modulates extracellular ATP
concentration and it has an interesting
phenotype such that it's expressed in a
scanner tissue right after birth but by
about 1 or 2 years of age it becomes
specifically expressed actually in beta
cells so we are wondering if this switch
in phenotype may have implications for
the pro-inflammatory ATP rich
environment and and how these cells
might respond to that so again we're
interested in those cellular
interactions as well as kind of
generally how the islet micro
environment influences development
so I think it's clear how the types of
biological questions that we're asking
in our laboratory are really well-suited
for the codec system so one of the first
things that we did when we first
purchased the system was just start
thinking about the antibody panel that
we would be building and how we would be
conjugating our own custom antibodies so
this is a straightforward labeling
protocol that takes only about 4 hours
it could be down to benchtop and I just
want to emphasize here that it was
really helpful for us to go over the pre
pre conjugated list of codex antibodies
that are available for my Koya because
that really then determines how you
choose the specific barcodes that are
most appropriate for the custom
conjugation
and just to give you an idea of what
this process is like it first comes with
it comes with all of the reagents in the
kit but first it's just a step of
concentrating and priming the antibody
and then annealing to those all ago
barcodes that are that are produced by
Koya and shipped to you so after that a
reaction occurs you'll then just go
through a few steps to purify the
conjugated antibody and then run a
protein gel just to verify that
conjugation occurred so here I'm showing
a simple protein gel and if you zoom in
on these two lanes here that I've
highlighted the band on the left there
represents a loaded antibody that is
unconjugated so you can see the weight
of that antibody determined where it
where it flows in the gel and then on
the right here you can see that that the
molecular weight of that sample has now
shifted due to the addition of the Ala
go barcode so this type of QC just
verifies that in fact the chemistry was
successful and that the barcode is now
attached to the antibody and I've done
this now for 11 different antibodies and
in my hands have had success with
successfully using them in our panel and
eight of those instances and I'll just
note here that all of the antibodies
that I've had or almost all of the
antibodies I've attempted to label have
been monoclonal and they've all been
free of carrier proteins which is a
requirement for the labeling procedure
and once you've verified that the
barcodes have in fact conjugated to your
antibody the next step is to perform a
staining validation which actually just
happened on your bench top again not not
with the machine and that's really the
step where you get to assess how
successful D conjugation really was
so for that procedure the goal is really
been to allow the user to specifically
titrate the antibody as well as
validated in the tissue of interest that
will be used ultimately in the Codex
machine so this procedure is done in six
low plates just like a regular codex
experiment so you're actually using the
coverslips that you've prepared that dr.
carlson mentioned before and then you're
just subjecting them to the regular
codex antibody incubation procedure so
in this case you're incubating with the
primary antibodies or the primary
antibodies that houses uni colleges and
then you'll add the codex reporters and
this stuff that kind of simulates what
happens in the Codex machine during an
experiment but in this case it'll be
done on your bench top so in most cases
the recommendation is that you use a
conjugate the the newly conjugated
antibody that you've just conjugated and
then you also use a conjugated antibody
that has already been validated so maybe
a marker that stains the same type of
cells that you're looking at ana marker
that seems the different to account for
kind of a positive and negative control
and then once you've done that you'll
mask your coverslip and actually
visualize that stain to see and assess
how your conjugated antibody has
performed now we went ran into a little
bit of trouble first thing because since
we're working in pancreatic tissue a lot
of the antigens that were interested in
recognizing are not previously validated
codex antibodies and so we knew we were
going to have to figure out how to
modify this procedure in order to run
positive and negative controls of
antibodies that were not previously
validated and so what we came up with
was in addition to standing with our
newly conjugated antibody
we also added an unlabeled antibody to
that incubation step and then the before
we incubated with those codex reporters
we actually added a traditional
secondary antibody and incubated just in
the storage buffer that's provided with
it with the staining kit from Akoya and
this allowed us to say
absolutely visualized both traditional
antibody and codex antibody on the same
slide so that was really key and helping
us to feel confident that our newly
conjugated antibodies were staining the
correct cells
and this lie just is a list of the
markers that we've been using in our
tissue samples and I'll be showing you
some images here in the next few slides
but I wanted to give you a sense of the
pre conjugated and validated antibodies
that come from McCoy as those are shown
highlighted in blue and then also the
antigens that we've prepared as custom
conjugated antibodies and you can see
that they represent a mix of different
cell types and also obviously have a
range of different corresponding
reporters so that we can efficiently use
multiple fluorophores in each cycle
during our codex run
a narc system here at Vanderbilt is is
integrated with the camp scope the BC X
800 the images I'll show you here are
using an APO 20x lens and the filter
cubes that we are using are the Jaffe
GFP trip C which is recognizing the 550
wavelength and then on the side five
so this image here is a representative
of one of our tissue sections that were
interested in learning more about this
this sample actually comes from a donor
that died very soon after birth so this
is really the kind of mid development of
a pancreas and I mentioned before this
tissue was fixed lightly in PSA prior to
embedding and freezing in an Oct media
and then the kind of experimental
outline of this image is is listed in
the top right hand corner but we were
using 8 codec cycles which were six of
which had antibodies and mauls the other
two were just adapt efore registration
purposes and then we used these 18
antibodies that I showed you a couple
slides back and this particular image
came from about nine by nine tiles at
20x so we took nine Z planes and then
the codec software during the processing
selected the best best focus plane and
you can see in the bottom left hand
corner I'm showing you different cell
types that are highlighted in this
particular panel so although we didn't
use 18 antibodies only seven are shown
in this particular image just for
purposes of color and visualizing and so
you can see that very quickly that the
compartments of the pancreas that I
showed you in those initial images and
introduction are very easily visualized
by these codex antibodies particularly
the blood vessels shown in red as well
as the endocrine cells or islet clusters
that are shown in that yellow green and
blue color
and then here is just zooming a little
bit more so you can start to get a sense
of the resolution from these images and
again we've used a mixture of both the
pre validated pre conjugated Akoya
antibody of with our antibodies and and
that's really enabled us to highlight
multiple different compartments of this
tissue
and I wanted to give you a sense also of
the range of antibodies so this is all
the same image the same experiment but
just kind of broken down into different
markers visualized so the top left-hand
corner shows the individual types of
endocrine cells that were able to to
look at depending on which which being a
body combination the top right shows
some of the vascular structure as well
as some of immune cells that are
highlighted by C 4 and C 89 the bottom
left hand is the image similar to the
image I showed in the previous slide
particularly highlighting the epithelium
shown with the cytokeratin and you can
see some little magenta dots indicating
proliferating cells through ki67 and
then the bottom right hand panel again
is starting to really phenotype the
particular immune cells that we see
around islets and the develop in
pancreas so you can see we've used a
combination of markers or recognized
macrophages and other other cell types
to start to be able to phenotype these
cells further and then I wanted to give
you a quick preview of the reason that
we've chosen to use the slightly fixed
tissue
so we're you'll see here these two
different tissues unfortunately they're
not from donors of the exact same age
but kind of a similar developmental
stage so on the left is just a fresh
frozen tissue which is one of the
recommended starting points for the
Codex system and then on the right will
be the lightly fixed tissue that we've
kind of developed in our laboratory so
in this first this first row shows some
of the Ocoee pre conjugated antibodies
and as you can tell from the images they
perform quite well in both the fresh
frozen and the lightly fixed tissue so
you can see that this resolution is is
very good isolating both individual
cells as well as structures but then
when you start to look at the islet
cells in particular which we find are
the most sensitive to fixation
procedures you can really appreciate I
hope from these images that using the
light basics
like fixation protocol really helps us
to preserve the integrity of the cell to
the cellular shape and also to ensure
that the antibodies are recognizing the
antigens that that they're designed to
so I just wanted to give you kind of a
side-by-side comparison of our
experience using those antibodies and
this slightly different type of tissue
okay as I mentioned we will only have
this system for a couple of months so we
actually haven't had the opportunity to
do a lot of the really exciting analysis
yet however I did want to give you an
example of the types of tools that can
be applied to images using the built-in
multiplex analysis view or math so this
is an image similar to the ones I've
shown previously and once these images
have been acquired what I've actually
been able to do is to use the software
in the mouse to isolate and kind of
annotate the different cellular their
self self subpopulations within the
pancreas so you can see in this little
box in the right hand corner a plot of
individual cells within the image that
are and their expression levels of two
of the markers that were interested in
so on the x-axis is chroma green and a
which marks all endocrine cells and then
c-peptide which marks beta cells on the
y axis and so I've drawn here a gate
similar to the way you would draw a key
using a flow cytometer in order to
specify which cells are positive for
both of these markers and then I can
then assign those to a specific
population now you can also have the
software do this automatically without
any kind of the user directed input but
since these tissues are a little bit
challenging to segment sometimes we
chose to do this kind of directed
approach at least for now
so once I've chosen this gate I can
essentially then apply the algorithms
within the software to go through my
entire image and annotate which cell
types are are located at each XY point
so here the purple dots that you see are
identifying non endocrine cells and then
the yellow blue and pink
are actually identifying the three of
the specific underground cell types so
we're interested in analyzing further
and then this is a Veroni plot actually
just an overlay here of the image but
you really get the sense of how
intricate and how what high resolution
we're going to be able to map these
specific cell types and so some of the
things that we're going to do in the
future will involve applying the multi
marker analysis tools that dr. Carlson
mentioned before in order to answer some
of the questions that we are asking
about the interactions between cell
types and thank Ria's
so just in conclusion I wanted to let
everyone know that we were able to
successfully integrate our key
microscope to be able to integrate with
the codec software and perform image
acquisition and that also our experience
with easily being able to custom
conjugate our antibodies really allowed
us to personalize an antibody panel that
could highlight multiple pancreatic
compartments and then we did find that
the codex antibodies that were designed
for this fresh frozen tissue can
actually detect antigen successfully in
our lightly fixed tissue and then as I
alluded to we're definitely going to be
using and applying the multi markers
facial analysis tools and math to help
us determine where endocrine cells are
interacting with immune so particularly
we're interested in macrophages and then
we also want to expand and adapt our
panel to apply to other developmental
cohorts as well as type-2 diabetes to be
able to kind of get a deep phenotyping
of the different cells that are present
in the micro environment I just wanted
to thank a couple members of my lab
particularly nathaniel hart who did a
lot of the initial characterization of
the the human pancreas development after
birth and also our collaborators at
Stanford some Kim and Yong Tang who have
been a great help to us in helping to
identify antibodies that are good
candidates for conjugation and kind of
getting up helping getting us up and
running so I think with that we are
going to transition to our Q&A
okay thank you dr. Saunders and dr.
Carlson for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we will answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started
dr. Carson let's kick off with this
question have you seen any steric
hindrance between antibodies with panels
of a larger size for example 25 to 30
markers
so that's a good question and this is
something that we have tested and we
have not observed steric hindrance for
large antibody panels and we also have a
white paper actually for download on our
website detailing how we validate our
antibodies which addresses this question
thank you and you I'm going to stick
with you dr. Carson you just showed a
list of mouse and human antibody is
compatible with codex is this the same
list of antibodies that are commercially
available and most up to date and is
there a shareable list of community
antibodies
so there is in that list included a
subset of antibodies that are available
as validated antibodies from Koya and we
know that those lists of antibodies work
with codex i'm happy to share any
antibody list with customers offline
very good thank you let's go to our next
question
how does this platform deal with and
overcome autofluorescence so there's
there's two ways in which we overcome
autofluorescence
one way is through background
subtraction so in using the codex we
have the ability to hybridize and be
hybridized codex reporters what that
enables us to do is run blank cycles
which we have no codex reporters in that
blank cycle only Dappy that gives us a
baseline background which we can
subtract as non signal to go forward and
remove auto fluorescence we also have
the ability for FFP tissue to use the
size 7 channel instead of the 50 channel
to navigate away from that high auto
fluorescence
thank you now can the output of the
Codex processor be a multi-layer TIFF
krisi this is stay and I can answer that
so we've actually been able to process
our images in a way that the the proper
codecs processor itself will stitch
together an image depending on the the
type of scope you use and when you open
that image in the in the image j suite
you're then able to manipulate it just
like you really can with any image and
image J and so you can export it as an
ome TIFF or if you have another file
format you prefer you can do those
manipulations and an export those
directly from the image J with the using
the mouse
Thank You dr. Saunders kymmie images be
exported and could they be used in other
software platforms for analysis like
image J or similar
so I can take this question and the
answer is simply yes
they're just TIFF images that are
produced so you can go ahead and use
them with any third party or alternative
image analysis software that you'd like
to use
we have some great questions coming in
let's say what fluorescent channels are
available and will this be increased
right so that's another good question
that can help address so the
fluorescence channels that we're going
to be using are the the Dappy the 488 @o
v 50 this I five and four FFPE the alexa
fluor 750 channels and I don't have any
information about whether or not that
will be increased at this time
next question is the empirical success
judged by the gel electrophoresis
electrophoresis result actual tissue
staining or both so the answer to that
is both the number I showed there the 8
out of 11
those were antibodies that have been
successfully used in our panel so I
think actually 10 out of the 11 were
successfully conjugated based on the
protein gel and then two of them for
whatever reason did not did not retain
their their signal within the tissue
afterwards but yeah we definitely go
through the whole process before calling
it a success
next question is you're in your antibody
development did you test how long the
antibody would last in other words how
many cycles could you go without losing
signal
I'm sorry can you repeat the question I
can absolutely in your antibody
development did you test how long the
antibody would last in other words how
many cycles could you go without losing
signal sure so that's a great question
and I can speak to that so we've gone
for internally tested 16 cycles without
seeing a loss of antigen detection and I
think a paper was recently published
using codex where they tested 33 cycles
and saw no loss of detection of the
target antigen so I can say very
confidently that we do not see a loss of
signal from or loss of signal in the
ability to detect that target antigen
thank you now I just want to quickly
remind our audience we have so many
great questions coming in those
questions that we are unable to answer
today due to time restraints and those
that come in during the on-demand period
they will be answered be of it email
address you provided at the time of
registration
okay so let's jump to our next question
when titrating the antibody did you
formally calculate a signal noise or was
this more qualitative so for for the
antibodies that we conjugated ourselves
it was a more of a qualitative analysis
and I'm not sure if dr. Carlton can
speak about the recommended titrations
for the Okoye antibodies
sure so we we titrate the majority of
our antibodies in our control tissues
for our valid advanced body there are
some subsets of tissues that we titrate
specifically for those tissues of
interest and I'm happy to have a
dialogue on on how we do that separately
after the webinar
Thank You dr. Carlson and dr. Sanderson
now our next question dr. Krauss and
this one's for you how do you deal with
autofluorescence and sspe tissue
great so I think we we might have
touched on that a little bit earlier but
just to reiterate we have two modalities
to deal with this there is the ability
to do background subtraction running a
blank cycle and then also using alexa
fluor 750 instead of the 50 channel
deaf defenders has come over to you with
antibodies that you used for custom
codex conservation already verified
through IHC previously yeah that's a
great question so definitely all of the
antibodies that we attempted conjugation
with were antibodies that we had already
screened so we just did that on regular
slides using traditional and you have
chemistry and then once we were
confident that they were working well in
those tissues then we were then we would
move over to the conjugation process
dr. Saunders Jeff Carlson is codex
compatible with TMA you scored course
site yeah it's a good question so yes it
is compatible with TM a course just like
the rest of the tissues you just need to
section that TM a onto a coverslip
very good no but stick with you what
antigen retrieval is recommended for
FFPE samples yeah that's the question we
get quite commonly
and so this antigen retrieval is
actually a lot like traditional antigen
which people there's some heat involved
and then either citrate and or EDTA and
the clones you're using to stain your
tissue actually determine whether you're
going to use citrate and/or the tryst
EDTA buffer
Thank You jarred across from that stick
with you real quick can codex data be
analyzed by third-party pipelines or
software packages absolutely
excellence okay dr. Saunders let's jump
over to you how long does it take from
tissue preparation and staining to
downstream data analysis for the 18
marker panel yeah
so that's really going to depend on a
couple different variables the actual
depth shop staining itself doesn't take
very long so what I mean it's comparable
to a regular miss communis to chemistry
so it probably takes including the
antibody incue bation excuse me about
five hours of prep time and then once
you get on the actual codex machine you
know it depends on how large your
imaging region is really as the major
factor there so I think in the images
that I showed in this presentation that
I would say the average time for the
experiment on the instrument was roughly
eight hours eight or nine and then
you're looking at another couple hours
of processing which of course can be
running on a different computer while
you know while your codex machine is
still doing something else and we really
haven't done a large majority of
analysis yet so I can't really speak to
that I think it kind of depends on how
granular you want to get but yeah I
would say from start to finish
probably you're looking at at least
twelve to fifteen hours of kind of
getting the the data out
Thank You dr. Saunders now let's stick
with you how you store all the data
generated from each run and as you scale
up codex experiments how do you plan to
address data storage yeah this is a kind
of a source of concern for us just
because we are planning to screen a
large volume of tissues so we have some
network associated storage available at
our institution that we're taking
advantage of as well as some cloud-based
backup and and some other servers
available so I think it definitely is a
situation where you want to have a
conversation with the IT department or
the infrastructure within your
institution or company to make sure that
you have kind of the beyond wit to be
able to store these large image files
sometimes you know to a gigabyte for
just a single experiment so I think in
the same way that you know sequencing
data requires a lot of storage space and
of kind of forethought and planning when
you implement a new system you can't you
just kind of have to be ready for that
influx of data
dr. Saunders now here's a question how
large are these images and what kind of
IT support is necessary
that's great so I'll take that question
so that the size of the image is going
to be dependent on the size of the
tissue so it's hard to give a firm
number for that but we're on the scale
of like gigabytes of data here not
megabytes and in terms of the IT support
we help you with the installation and
setup of everything you know whether you
want to set up some servers or have an
alternative so that's beyond what our
standard installation is that's that's
totally up to you we're flexible and you
know it really depends on what you want
to do
q can I use flow software to analyze
output data yeah that's that's also a
good question so the two types of files
that are produced by the codecs are the
FCS files and the TIFF images and so
flow data the flow software is going to
be able to process those FCS files so
yes
okay thank you and this is for dr.
Saunders
what would your evaluation of the
efficiency of codexes cell segmentation
pipeline
did you try an alternative method such
as cell profile yeah that's a good
question and for those of you who don't
study the pancreas it's kind of a
difficult organ to work with in some
cases so cell segmentation is a little
bit more challenging than some other
tissues so we we didn't evaluate really
another pathway side by side we
typically in our lab used indica
software to to do our analysis our
algorithm assist analysis so you know
comparing it to the indica labs software
that I've used I was dated just as good
if not better but I haven't I haven't
gone through in a detailed fashion and
compared it to other system
thank you
what was what is the optimal tissue
thickness for codex analysis
so I can speak a little bit to this so
the tissue has to be between five and
ten microns thick so it needs to be
somewhere in that range
and I think that the tissue all of the
tissues that I showed you were between
eight and ten microns so you know
depending on how large your the section
that you're trying to image is or sorry
how large the area is that you're trying
to image you will sometimes need to
adjust the you know the range of z-stack
so when like I mentioned the the
processor during the analysis there
sorry pre analysis during the processing
phase will select the best plane
essentially for each tile and so the
thickness of your section there might
mean you have to take more or less
details in order to get that best focal
plane
thank you now can you do multi-point
imaging adjust isolates and exclude
exocrine tissue
so I think this this may be a question
about like regions of interest and that
is great he may be able to answer this a
little bit better than me but you can
set multiple areas of analysis during
different ordering the same imaging run
so you wouldn't necessarily have to take
that full section image like the one I
show you could choose individual
locations within it to image
yeah I think you've captured that while
you could to to image those regions or
just do the analysis on those regions
afterward whichever way you want to
manage manage the data
thank you can you do multi-point
envelopes so sorry um I was reading the
same one but we have time for one final
question and let's wrap with this one
and dr. Saunders I believe this one's
for you do you see the need to go up to
a 40 X objective in the future yeah
that's an interesting thing to think
about for us I we've traditionally stuck
at 20 X and feel that that's an adequate
kind of compromise between really being
able to capture the multicellular nature
of the eyelids but also to be able to
really easily capture the you know kind
of spatial organization of the the
cross-sections of the tissue that we're
interested in so I would say that the
majority of our work is kind of looking
at cellular interactions and not so much
at focusing in on individual cells so we
don't have any plans in the near future
to go up to 40 X but I think certainly
it would be you know would produce
beautiful images so maybe maybe someday
we would consider that
okay you know we're going to fit in one
quick question and dr. Saunders this is
for you when validating custom
antibodies in the pancreas with a
primary secondary approach did you use a
clone targeting a different epitope
oh that's a great question yes so in
most cases I actually used a completely
different antigen but an antigen that
stain for the same cell if that makes
sense
so you definitely could use the same an
antibody that was targeting a different
epitope of the same antigen but in our
case we actually just completely
switched but in a population that we
still knew should should be positive for
the same markers
thank you now I want to thank dr.
Saunders and dr. Carlson for their time
today and for their important research
and we've had an excellent Q&A session
and I'd like to also extend that thanks
out to our audience for joining us and
for their interesting questions again
questions we did not have time for today
there were some that came in we don't
have time to answer and those that are
submitted during our on-demand period
will be addressed by dr. Saunders and
dr. Carlson via the email address you
provided at the time of registration now
before we go we'd like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor a Koya Biosciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
now a poll will pop up on your screen
and your participation is greatly
appreciated this webcast can be viewed
on-demand
and Mavericks will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thanks for joining us today
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day